une production du studio sf
bio sans filtre le podcast où on parle
lorsqu'on avec nos invités date cidj ph
quand avec moins d'hommes plantes vous
le savez ici au studio sfr lui notre
espace mais en ce moment on est en
rénovation
on est en train de développer deux
autres espaces de nouveaux espaces
uniques pour enregistrer vos podcasts
excellent temps d'avoir accès au
matériel aux techniciens à tout ce que
vous voulez pas vous occuper mec ça vous
tente pas non plus d'être dans un décor
que beaucoup de productions québec vous
inquiétez pas ça s'en vient au moment où
est ce que je vous parle vous allez
pouvoir très prochainement réserver les
autres espaces vous allez en entendre
parler davantage aller pour sur notre
site web du 17.6 certainement cette
semaine c'est un grand honneur
[Musique]
louise sigouin que j'adore que j'ai
découvert dans l'émission si on sait
mais qui est sexologue est qui qui qui
accompagne en fait les participants
destination le et des gens et les
couples dans la vie pour
qu'il pourrait aider à acheminer
apprendre davantage sur eux sur eux à
briser leurs patins elle s'excuse on
approche des cinq dualité cirma
passionnante cet exercice de découvrir
nos qu'elles sont nous dualité à la
ronde on s'ouvre on se connaît on y
pense pas que c'est super le fun et et
super passionnante elle est attachante
elle est la connaissons son sujet et
bienveillante on l'a d'or c'était
vraiment un grand plaisir à ce moment
une excellente conversation
qui nous permet de comprendre plusieurs
affaires sur le roussillon on vieillit
on accumule les expériences on a des
échecs et des réussites puis d'essayer
de comprendre mieux c'est très
intéressant avant de vous laisser la
conversation on va les remercier nous
commençons le pas-de-calais cette
semaine et présenté par memscap si vos
ballons l'air la barbe du père noël
c'est le temps de passer chez man skate
on a ici dans mes mains le lendemain 4.0
qui le fuit pas par excellence pour les
bases pour la barre pour n'importe
quelle partie du corps cwa leur pelouse
donc dans la douche potes des ghost in
the skin cette technologie vous empêche
de vous [ __ ] ici moi ce qu'ils peuvent
utiliser pour tout don aussi je pense
qu'ils portent liste pour tout de suite
risque pourtant auxerre je rentre
sa vie dans le petit paquet quel point
zéro avec les boxeurs avec le procureur
qui grimpe si ton honneur pour les bases
avec des os pour les bases tout ça avec
moi avec les craquements pour ce soit
moi que je tiendrai régulièrement quand
j'ai besoin d'un petit coup de
nettoyants soient départis de
rafraîchissant pour avec meilleur point
je trouve que garde des sceaux fringues
à dessein une belle petite odeur puis
c'est toujours possible dans leur
patronne ils ont plein de promo pour le
temps des fêtes souffle acheter un
cadeau à votre être cher c'est le temps
de le frère pis vous pouvez aussi
utiliser notre code promo qui le sans
filtre pour 20% de rabais et le shipping
gratuit sauter là dessus c'est le temps
d'utiliser même script d'acheter minsk
est de faire don de la propre culte
savez quoi faire le podcast
d'aujourd'hui est présenté par tachnag
commentaires de tout ce qui est
alcoolisé au studio et qui dit hochelaga
dit créativité nouveautés et on a deux
votre candidature et nous donc la forêt
noire une autre claque de siroter
l'autre soir et on l'a beaucoup apprécié
des notes de caramel salé de cacao des
cerises quand même forte 6.5 % une bière
qui réchauffe bien qui fait vraiment
temps des fêtes un peu sucré mais pas
trop vraiment agréable je la recommande
fortement sinon une nouvelle entrée dans
leur série régulière si la west coast à
épier pour les femmes dans les pieds
comme moi je suis évidemment le goût
doublonner a marre j'en ai payé mais
aussi des touches d'agrumes et des
douches de des touches sa pin est en
fait qui vient du mérite beau ministre
c'est l'athlète twisto schlague qui
vient de mettre encore dany voter dans
leur bière honnêtement ces deux bières
leurs parents tant d'efforts et c'est un
mot si j'adore goto un must prenez le
comme vous voulez lors de conversations
affamés pis si vous voulez savoir où
vous en procurer aller sur leur site web
et vous allez trouver une carte
interactive avec toutes leurs points de
vente tant d'effets en septembre
découvrez on découvre tout le monde
ensemble g et ce chez vous avait capoté
comme nous on a capoté merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup d'être là ce matin
on me conforte à
la blonde est extrêmement jalouse que je
t'ai rencontre
mais c'est drôle parce qu'ils aient
plusieurs personnes que j'ai dit que je
suis avocat ce avec toi qui est déjà
activement jaloux j'aimerais tellement
sale a rencontré tellement hot puis
tiendra mardi tour de monde s'y met il
ya quelque chose avec louis sigouin et
parce que les particules il vraiment
est-ce que les gens ce que les gens te
reconnaissent dans la rue
j'imagine que les gens
moi j'ai fait occupation 2 fait que j'ai
fait de la télé un petit peu puis je te
mets ton les gens ont la led de voir
puis pense qu'il commence fiction comme
moins gêné de venir parler d'affaires
qui te regarde pas du tout mais ne
viennent que toit sur la tête terrible
et jan de maere de parler de leur coupe
la première seconde du doigt mais c'est
fou tout le monde cette préoccupation là
et les gens ne font pas cela au
contraire c'est vrai que ma board un peu
comment il salue comme si on vivait
ensemble comme s'il connaissait c'est
très très familier revenez y réalise que
ok c'est moi mais au contraire c'est
plus pour me dire le bienfait que ça
fait fait une pause pétition ils veulent
pas d'intervention c'est qu'on est
depuis que cette émission la joue on y
côtoie en femme et mon homme l'écoutent
maintenant ça crée des belles
conversations puis ça ça me fait le plus
grand plaisir qui m'interpelle beaucoup
puis je pensais que je mentirais au
début parce qu'on avait le masque puis
dix millénaires pied puis ma foi ce soit
ma voix qui l'interpellent jusqu'en mai
jusqu'au bout à l'autre
il
sait ce que je connaissais le courage de
changer mes plans
et vous madame si quinn jeter de l'eau
avec maman c'est juste très gentil puis
à quel point cela des bienfaits bst et
sur l'exercice vraiment suscité d
introspection que les gens se posent des
questions puis que ça éveille des
questionnements pour être meilleurs en
voilà mais c'est ce qu'ils font
exception les cdd et missions de
daigneault problème est d'avoir le
regard professionnel à travers tous
c'est ce qui fait la particularité des
thèmes sur le psy qui fait que ces îles
et les candidats les participants font
un cheminement faisant se met à maison
en l'écoutant des fois tu te reconnais
dans certains bars honneur je vois tu te
reconnais dans certains
dans certaine dynamique où toi quand
même chose que tu écris donc ça à maison
aussi
la particularité du docu-réalité de
sciences et mais c'est que les gens
continuent de vivre dans leur quotidien
fait qu'on l'a on les voit dans leur
attitude dans leurs habitudes dans leur
façon dyke cet effet de ce processus
d'identification fait nous on finit tous
par se retrouver quelque part dans une
façon de se comporter dans une
maladresse dans un commentaire puis je
pense que c'est ce que qui
inconsciemment on est assis tranquille
dans son salon je te coup ça nous touche
à fait comme un monde où ça me ressemble
s'assemble quelqu'un que je connais et
puis c'est ce qui nous aide même si on
n'est pas directement impliqué à faire
le processus puis à se poser des
questions tout ça fait 25 ans que tu
travailles là dedans et puis je ne
reviendrai jamais pensé dans au milieu
d'un jeu télé un jour non j'avais
beaucoup à coeur de trouver une façon si
j'ai fait des conférences pendant
longtemps en disant qu est ce que je
pourrais faire parce que le besoin
yellow d'apprendre à ce qu'on ait des
outils pour leur parti c'est comme ça se
prête donc être n'importe quelle
conversation de comment je peux faire
pour cheminer puis apprendre à me
connaître une mamie henry mais les gens
y manque d'outils fans et les
conférences pour moi c'était une façon
de me dire je donner de l'information
accessible à tous où les gens vont
pouvoir un peu ramené sur la maison
puisse interroger mais la télé à ma mort
a beau aborder parce que m sellal
idéatrice du projet c'est un projet oui
c'est quelqu'un que je connais depuis 25
ans dont acheté en totale confiance je
trouve et quel projet à cause de son
caractère éducatif y était génial puis à
cause de cette porte là tout est dit
conférence le temps que je me dis 2 il
ya pleinement le tir de la côte-nord à
l'abitibi où les gens peuvent avoir
accès sont bougés nécessairement de
consulter pour eux c'est des précieux
conseils des informations qui peuvent
certes beaucoup de différences dans leur
quotidien
on parlais tantôt de adam dans
l'émission les gens retournent dans leur
quotidien mais ça c'est quelque chose
justement qui que dans les émissions des
thèmes traditionnels ça se passe pas le
dire pour l'avoir vécu de première main
développer la
développe une relation qui est basée sur
sur quelque chose qui n'existe pas
vraiment ce qui est tellement hors de
temps de ta propre vie que tu peux même
pas toi même pas de repères de même pas
la même personne qui était dans ton
quotidien fait de reconnaître dans son
quotidien effectivement ça doit trouver
vraiment résonance assez forte chez les
gens qui sont chez eux et puis parce que
le quotidien le dos et
99% notre vie c'est on se lève puis on
est chez nous le tipi on est dans le pré
à nos affaires et puis on voit où ils
vivent les amis qu'ils ont la femme et
les enfants comment y circulant toutes
les demandes de levée puis je pense que
ça contribue à ce qu'on puisse
identifier se retrouver puis avoir un
regard bienveillant je trouve que les
gens ça les aide à voir que différentes
façons différentes personnalités
différentes sur un comportement pied ça
crée quelque chose de plus accueillant
pour la différence du que tu décris au
site et les amis l'environnement tout se
sait tout des choses quand même qu'ils
qui viennent jouer grint ainsi une
relation qui sont importants au final ce
nul c'est quand tu te rends compte
quelques uns notamment dans un contexte
exceptionnel plus tard il est finalement
son mode de vie son parti pis y'a rien
qui concorde dans tout quant aux sept
personnes dont ça joue quand même
beaucoup oui puis c'est quand qu'on
rencontre des gens on se présente tout
sous notre meilleur jour si on est beau
en effet il est extraordinaire mais dans
les faits on se donne rendez-vous mon la
personne et du ponctuel être disponibles
a vite fait en fonction de ses valeurs
ou à le juste lancée sur fait que ce
contexte le sait vraiment représentatifs
de la vie de tous les jours donc surtout
ce
que j'ai dit je sais pas comment appeler
seul j'ai cancellé des relations justes
pour un retard
qu'on s'était donné parce que t'es trop
inconfortable
non parce que ben parce que moi je pose
dans ma tête à moi c'était super
important de la ponctualité fait que je
vais me jeter le 15 mai avant un petit
je me taperais métier rendre le jeu plus
alors ici à l'île aux personnes qui
n'ont non
non moi j'ai un portrait
qui
disait avant qu'on commence qui était
dans le fond on rate à travers les
missions des sciences et mais tu vois
les candidats dans son bureau comme ce
serait normalement ouais mais tu vois
pas l'extérieur à trois pas les
émissions non parce que puis quand tu
les écoutes après tu été surpris parce
que tu vois souvent ou c'est ça ça
ressemble à ce que tu aurais pu imaginer
de ce que tu connais déjà des candidats
nous avons vu notre bureau mais
généralement c'est un bon reflet de ce
qui me raconte pas ce que dans la
démarche qu'ils font avec moi ils sont
très volontaires ils sont 1 ait dans
leurs capacités et le type parce que
l'extérieur on parle de mon dieu s'il ya
des contradictions mais dans leur façon
de se présenter à moi mais effectivement
ça correspond généralement à ce qu'ils
m'ont raconté à comme ils l'ont vécu
mais apprécié dans leur quotidien le
sait ce qu'il ya comme un autre regard
que le téléspectateur peut avoir
différemment du mieux mais moi c'est
même dans mon bureau c'est comme je vois
toujours derrière un comportement il est
peut-être une appropriée mais derrière
il ya toujours une bonne intention où il
ya toujours une bonne volonté avec moi
je reste toujours avec cette même
lunettes le quand je regarde les
émissions milieu je les vois dans leur
vie dans leur quotidien mais c'est une
réalité que j'aie jamais connue parce
que la personne qui me conseillent de la
voix pauvres dans son quotidien comme
nouvelle passat lequel je dis qu
est-ce que des fois t'es des fois
ci les participants imagine les gens qui
se rencontrent dans la vie
foutez brasse un peu ou du moins coûteux
leur disent les leurs quatre vérités de
foi ou cité pour qu'ils prennent
conscience de mon réparateur nous quoi
que ce soit ça doit être ça doit être un
des fils quand même d'être capable faire
bien passé quelque chose qui pourrait
être mal pris ou mal interprétés la
première chose à faire c'est de créer un
lien de confiance un organisme en août
dernier de confiance tout peut se dire
tout dépend de la façon dont se dire
mais si j'ai pas de lien j'essaie de
présenter une vérité à quelqu'un qui
n'est pas en confiance en ce que ce soit
moi toi ou peu importe que quelqu'un
d'autre ça fonctionne repos donc c'est
important de créer un lien de confiance
pu apprécier moi je leur demande souvent
d'où tu mon opinion est ce que mon
opinion professionnelle via mon opinion
mais je peux te dire quelque chose que
j'observe que les gens généralement ils
sont réceptifs puis à la limite on dit
j'ai su que tu me dises nos enfants
demain mais d'oraison l'acte i faut pas
perdre de vue que la personne qui me
consultent à consommer sur une base
volontaire
c'est un investissement financier quand
même avec les gens ils sont là pour
avoir un début et une fin à la démarche
fiction soucieux d'avoir quelque chose
des outils concrets des vérités qui vont
les uns des pigeons je veux dire quelque
chose qu'on aura la blonde indices
portant sur
ses pires je me suis déjà fait dire sa
part mon patron au monde où ça tellement
résonance parce que dans ma vie je me
fais souvent reprocher sauf et clos à
partir de l'autre devant cette admission
lors de leurs portes aux idées mais
c'est mon devoir de dire les choses
telles qu'ils sont présentés sinon ça
donne quoi tu en es mollo pour un nid
flatter dans le sens de la démarche est
commencé cherche bonne c'était pas un
mètre dans ta démarche
les gens qui sont rendus eux à consulter
à prendre 30 cet engagement le à
s'investir financièrement ce parce
qu'ils sont prêts puis c'est toujours la
même motivation dans toute ma carrière
jamais personne qui m'a zeil oui j'ai
quand même un petit 100 piasses a
investi par semaine le jeune vertu de
croissance l'évolution si toujours la
souffrance je suis capable ces
souffrances cette année deux patins de
cette année d'être taxé c'est le moteur
qui fait comme ok le choc j'étais
investi puis je veux que ça change
accuse on ne tourne dans le monde dans
la même direction une fois que le lien
de confiance est établie est-ce que
c'est plus des gens célibataires ou des
gens coupent viennent de moi et deux les
deux auteurs c'est des relations en
difficulté ou c'est des gens qui ont eu
des relations plus longtemps un point
tournant de l'heure leur vie qu'ils
veulent pas répéter les mêmes par tonne
vous n'avez pas idée de comment y ait
des gens qui sont seuls depuis très
longtemps ça me motivait beaucoup aussi
notre projection ce mais parce que
autant de des applications des sites
internet des façons diverses de
rencontrer les gens jamais aussi seul
parce que est quelque chose qui est très
expéditif qui fixe pour certaines
personnes n'ont pas le temps de se
présenter tels qu'ils sont et ont peu de
temps de voir la relation évolue et qui
sont déjà éjecté
ça fait vivre beaucoup de solitude aux
gens qui sont en démarche parce que
c'est un autre processus long et pau
dans la démarche qu'on avait avant ou en
apprenant à se connaître on avait un
collègue de travail où on avait une
voisine puis le coma tranquillement les
sentiments s'installer plus a laissé
place à quelque chose comme faut que je
fasse mon pitch rapidement je vais
demain vous arrive à loi
sinon je resterais éjecté ouais
techniquement ils vivent beaucoup de ce
fait beaucoup de si le papa ou des
coupes en difficulté parce que c'est
vrai qu'avec les quelques avec les les
applications rencontre les médias
sociaux toujours l'impression que si
c'est pas parfait de la première seconde
il ya un million d'autres options que
s'offre à toi mais en réalité pas
vraiment cela ne sera jamais parfait à
première selon dans le fond le nom me
donnez vous au moins trois rencontres
parce que la première rencontre où on
est plus sûr l'observer l'autre
asiatique aurait qu'est ce qui cloche
qu'est ce qui marche pas ou de se mettre
dans une position où faut que je sois
parfait parfait après l'autre en comble
un peu plus déposés on regarde acquis
qu'à 3e ont choisi c'est ce que si au
premier abord il ya quelque chose qui me
frappe qui contre-valeur obligé mais ça
dans une première rencontre c'est trop
dit rien c'est trop de pression mais
c'est la réalité est souvent il y en a
qui vont vite se faire rejeter ou qui
ont choisi de paille aller pour toutes
sortes de bonnes raisons puis c'est son
nez dans cette terre l'eau avec faut
trouver des façons d'entrer en relation
de se présenter avec le plus
d'authenticité possible je pense que
rendu là c'est notre meilleure carte à
jouer j'essaie aussi qui quitte à ne pas
créer raté l'émission j'ai l'impression
c'est que souvent au moment où est-ce
que met-on normalement ça aurait
déterminé outil c'est comme on encourage
à poursuivre poursuivre dépasser ce pays
comprendre ça puis même si ça finit pas
nécessairement mettons en relation
amoureuse b les deux vont peut-être
apprendre quelque chose sur moi même
puis apprendre quelque chose les
relations est ce que dans la ville
écoute ça c'est quelque chose qui me
fascine depuis le début de ma carrière
c'est tous milieux confondus de toutes
les groupes d'âge toutes les
orientations de tous les genres on
répète tous un par tonne qu'on a
appliqué a pris dans notre système
familial
il va s'améliorer il va se raffiner ont
fait ce qu aux danses en allant de quand
on arrive à ce moment charnière où c'est
comme le chemin confortable je devrais
aller plus loin
généralement les gens abandonnent mais
le dans l'émission volet acquis à cette
étape-ci vos mains du hasch manierez au
juge pas capables ils sont vos plus loin
mais comme tu dis on n'aura peut-être
pas un duo amoureux mais on va voir à
qui j'ai dépassé cet inconfort l'eau qui
fait que généralement je m'en veux parce
que tout au bas ça marche pas pu match
dans l'ensemble ça me dérange pas du
tout nos façons de réagir mais si on
arrive à travers 6 7 1 conforme à ce que
la prochaine relation que je veux
attirer mais à risque d'être moins
proche à mon patin mais c'est quelque
chose que je recommanderais cédant
contacté l'émission vu tout hello kitty
higgins à un pur
c'est justement ça peut être propice à
leur propre sur soi mais date du casque
est ce quelque chose que je
recommanderais d'envy mettons de même
quand il ya de dépasser leur apporter du
cancer devrait normalement oui mais ne
serait-ce que de le dire moi cette étape
slapshot de chips coiffeur à cette
étape-ci la relation si je me retenais
je quitterai la relation peut en parler
voici ce qui me dérange parce que ce
soit celle promise un confort trop moins
de patients c'est le faux nom de
répandre du foot ces flux et dont on
dirait qu'on se connaît depuis toujours
ce jour le mans l'a mené à une autre
étape d'engagement car c'est celle là
que ce com finalement il peut aussi
prompte ul que sur pied d'or mais
désordonnée et puis j'aime pas comment
il savait tout nos un confort parce que
le partant une session c'est une
blessure qui émergent
pis le comportement qu'on utilise la la
contourner mais c'est là que les
comportements à risque pourquoi pas
juste en parlait pas si toi aussi aller
plus loin que c'est surtout son nez dans
les mêmes valeurs pour ne plane intérêt
appuyé on a en partage des points
communs qu'est ce qu'on a à perdre paul
souply d'année mais petit en une semaine
un mois pourquoi essayer de faire les
choses sur un an il faut sortir du non
dit
à la fin oui cela gêne c'est souvent
seul le gros problème c'est tout dans le
non dit dans le fond puis personnes
communiquent vraiment on entretient que
6 tu es
amoureux puisque la bonne personne on
n'aurait pas à discuter de ce alors que
je sais pas qui est ce que ça devrait
être flux et de naturel salle deviez
mais avec le temps mon expérience dans
ce que je constate dans mon dos et avec
le temps les gens développent la
complicité puis ce qu'on pourrait
appeler au conflit ce trésor plus
rapidement et pour le pré 3 semaines de
rencontres
après trois semaines de rencontres ce
qui est très très compatibles se
souvient de la passion pc phone
profitons-en gaza pas parce que ça se
résorbe c'est une autre étape de la
relation est ce que tu remarques souvent
les coupes qui durent dans le temps
c'est l'école qui ça a été justement
plus loin comme comme progression
mettons plutôt que la passion parce que
tu es on voit toutes sortes de justement
de dynamique dans l'édition du bien
acquis c'est très très fort au début
puis calmes en et samar gobain sa tête
et d'autre que ses goûts des bus urbains
nécessairement mon genre habituel
puisque dalmat ses personnages des
coupes ça devient les plus belles
relations attend de moi ce que j'observe
c'est que j'en ai vu pour tous les goûts
le dit gekko qui sont connues depuis dix
jours après se sont mariés c'est trente
ans qu'ils sont ensemble mais j'en ai
donc parti sur des grosses patients puis
ça a terminé aussi bien orientées je
pense qu'il faut se donner cette
ouverture il ya des relations qui
commence sur l'amitié il ya des
relations qui commence lentement et en
acquis par compassion mais les gens qui
partent sur une passion il faut toujours
garder à l'esprit que ça va se résorber
on peut pas vivre d'une passion ou aux
baux de jus d'orange for mr pire on fait
juste c'est mes randonnées il fallait
travailler s'occuper de nos enfants se
réaliser puis c'est un choc le possible
sont très patients quand ça redescend ce
que on s'aime plus 11e différemment fait
que ce conseil la façon d'entrer en
relation plus débuts dans la mesure où
sans respect que le besoin de tout le
monde secret puisque j'en ai vu pour
tous les goûts mais c'est ce que moi je
prends prendre son temps je prends 10
relations sexuelles avant deux
rencontres à une première à la santé sus
de nojals et non seulement elle négocie
au loup
beaucoup c'est vrai que j'ai beaucoup
parce que s'est étalée sur une fois
semaine quasiment 2 moi mais ça permet
de voir la personne dans son quotidien
c'est exceptionnel qu'était harper scam
dit puisque a fait est ce que c'est que
ces conduire humain c'est les gens ils
se sont tellement fait dire toutes
sortes d'histoires parce qu on le fait
tous je suis belge punch extraordinaire
le 10 octobre de transport
gamescom ça permet sauf si jamais ça ne
se termine pas perdre à la sambre c -
souffrent quand ça se termine parce que
pilote à face et que si la personne
avait juste une rencontre sexuelle puis
moi je n'aspire jeunes attentes
amoureuses mais il va avoir un
déchirement le ceci étant dit c'est
juste sexuelle on est tous les deux la
même place à un niveau là bas de cinq
ans c'est bien dans un contexte amoureux
parce que moi j'étais sous l'impression
que l'âge appelons ceux chimie sexuelle
est un des facteurs importants pour un
couple de longue durée mathon puis si on
n'a pas du tout
j'aimerais mieux le savoir bab en se
mettant k qui après deux mois
d'engagement puits de découverte de la
personne mais c'est un très bon point
fait qu'il ya des gens qui vont dire en
nommant la chimie sexuelle c'est super
important faut je vais réussir
rapidement donc c'est plus comme une
attirance naturelle une alchimie
des papillons mais la sexualité
préserver cette intensité l'eau dans le
temps a beau passer par une autre façon
que juste la pulsion en fait d'un goûter
ou de fait que sa part un patient tant
mieux on valide ce n'est un moment donné
il faut que la sexualité prendre une
autre forme parce qu'on n'est pas
toujours aussi passionné fait qu'à va
passer par un aspect physique un aspect
motif un aspect intellectuelle c'est
toutes ses dimensions mais qui finissent
par s'investir par amour avec le temps
c'est plus aussi pulsionnel et physique
mais c'est par amour psicom aux jeunes
c'est comme un cri fléchi monde jane
pitt check-list exprimé au tce comment
la défense on pointe pelée et quelque
chose qui maintient d un côté ou de
l'autre voir le même travail à faire
scarlett de le vérifier négocions soit
pour sa
[Rires]
présidente nous notre génération à schio
thio chin doit faire le sait comme le
lunetier c'est curieusement la nature
même de l'application est pour une
rencontre sexuelle que ce mal est si
faible comme ca sur tm 9a rei badauds et
savate dans 10 buts
et pearl à pitre aux médecins on peut
juste prendre notre temps pour les
choses différentes sur ce que les gens
suivent encaissés dans la proposition
que je leur fais j'ai toujours fait en
une relation sexuelle cinq mois après je
découvre que cette personne n'est pas
tout à fait celle qui représentait plus
chine est supputé coeur et répété c'est
pas trop mon sac faisons les choses
différemment en espérant voir
si des gens les seuils de trois
rencontres de la première c'est déjà
gagnant oui ça nous donne des éléments
pis ça ne trouve ça permet à l'esprit
peau au coeur de s'ouvre et parce qu'au
delà d attirance physique il ya toutes
les qualités qu'un comment cette
personne à ce qu'on porte au restaurant
quand on allait au cinéma je prends une
marge est fatigué après cinq mineurs dos
tellement dans les activités de façon
d'apprendre à découvrir l'obsession
qu'on présente aussi dans si on se met
dans les activités en hachant ouellet il
y en a qui sont plus pudiques puis ça
parle de l'individu que ça plaise ou
paul
qu'est-ce qui est ce qui est à la base
du besoin de l'être humain d'être en
couple
qu'est-ce qui vous qu'est ce qui crée
savent pas ce qu'ils étaient on pense à
aux animaux non humains bien ne pas tant
que ceux qui créent des couples pour
pour longtemps
quand quelqu'un qu'on pense aux humains
et bien on dirait que on dirait que
comme une tête une conception sociale
qui a été créée autour du couple qu'est
ce qui est à la base de super pourquoi
encore aujourd'hui même si on essaie
maintenant de remettre de remettre en
question les conventions sociales les
créations social est ok mais on est
quand même ramené au couple mais c'est
un très bon point
c'est purement de mon expérience de rien
de scientifique dans ce que j'avance
mais bon d'abord les animaux ont besoin
d'être relié souvent les chevaux par
exemple les dauphins isolement y vivent
1 en garde en meute dès que je pense que
d'emblée l'être humain besoins
indéniable d'être relié je pense qu'on
l'a vu avec la pandémie même si on avait
des contacts virtuels des contacts texto
ce besoin le décevoir pour vrai de
socialiser il s'est manifesté comme
quelque chose de très important dans un
premier temps puis deux raisons parce
que c'est comme si même si c'est le
domaine souvent le plus souffrant on est
blessé on est rejetée abandonné on est
déçu on est trahie l'être humain a
beaucoup de mal à renoncer m où la vie
amoureuse j'en peux plus j'en ai
certains clients qu'ils l'ont fait mais
c'est la souffrance compris parce que
malgré tout sur saône autre raison je
pense qui explique le succès 6-2 science
mais c'est tout le monde cherche a
besoin le d'être exclusif d'être le
numéro un pour quelqu'un d'être la
personne qui fait la différence puis que
je pense que c'est ce besoin les qui
fait qu'on le pas de la même façon en
relation d'amitié on le pas de la même
façon en famille on le pas de la même
façon mais je pense que la particularité
du besoin d'être amoureux puis d'être en
couple c'est d'avoir ce regard exclusifs
l'un de l'autre que ce soit oui sexuels
et physiques mais aussi la première
personne qui est à peine sait-on
amoureux c'est ton amour je pense que
c'est ce qui explique les gens dans une
pop que ce besoin le ceci étant dit il
ya mille et une façons de vie la
relation amoureuse sur je pense que ça
l'a l'âge c'est à la lèvre la pression
peut le vit de façon polie amoureuse on
peut le vivre de façon très très
conventionnel on peut le vivre de mille
et une façons fait que ça enlève la
pression mais on a quand même ce besoin
autres je pense que besoin d'être aimé
si on déplie grand besoin de sion mais
bon on peut penser au travail puis la
particularité amoureuse
elle est seule et unique à la vie à
moudre aux besoins le il l'oeil effort
[ __ ] et niamey ondrais aussi que le
besoin est inverse de
tilley tellement d'histoires
d'infidélité de mon histoire de
mariage et qui finissent en d'ivoire et
mon histoire de que j'ai l'impression
qu'ils aussi une pulsion qui nous tire
en dehors un peu de doutes qu'il faut
qu'on apprendra à guider à combattre
luis borges passées à combattre mais à
vivre avec lui mais je pense que il faut
quand je suis en relation il faut parler
de ces nations là c'est quoi la place
qu'on veut donner à la fidélité
c'est quoi la fidélité pour toi montés
en neige gelée pas pénétrer ou je n'ai
pas embrassé hors jeu par moureu puis je
vous laisse imaginer ce que ça allait
dans mon bureau quand on part même
définition pigalle ils vivent la nature
de la blessure sans avoir parlé fac
foule déchaînée pis c'est normal en
relation d'avoir du désir d'avoir un
attrait d'avoir un coup de coeur pour
quelqu'un d'autre c'est qu'est ce que je
fais qu'est ce que ça dit de moi est-ce
que samedi que je suis insatisfait dans
la relation est ce que samedi que marla
sur manque de pitié est ce que on a le
droit d'ouvrir cette porte vous est ce
qu ont eu cette entente là entre nous à
partir de là quand les enfants sont
clairs ils peuvent changer parce que
comme un être humain ont changé ma
conception 18 ans est pas la même à 35
paie pas la même à 53 c'est que d'être
des femmes qui ont dit et moi le shanxi
est infidèle deux temps trois mouvements
les recoins de changer y créera possible
mais quand ça arrive à cause d'un
contexte à cause la vie qu'ils ont créés
à cause d'un paquet de facteurs c'est
beau aussi
action réaction pleut il revisite cette
notion l'obtient par pear garde puis il
y en a d'autres qui effectivement vont
le faire mais je pense qu'il faut
réfléchir à ce avant que ça arrive
oui peeters ibsa votre soin d'anna non
pour moi s'est classé que là pour toi
mais la définition à commence ou paca
fait clairement on est comme être humain
a tiré par mille et une choses est ce
qu'on répond à tout ce qui nous a tués
c'est que ce soit matérielle que ce soit
financier que ce soit une autre personne
faut juste avoir ces conversations là
mais je pense que c'est le propre de
l'être humain d'être attirés vers autre
chose que d'être attirés par la
nouveauté puis de mesurer ses pas
l'impact c'est quoi les conséquences que
ces corrections ci-dessus d'années cette
permission là
ça revient encore à la discussion lundi
à la conversation puis à la
communication dans le fond c'est sûr que
là tout le temps la réponse qui arrivent
afin de tout l'est toutes les
consultations avec des clients de toutes
tailles sur les tubes au final parce que
c' était capable de bien qui le problème
c'est ça le problème c'est d'être
capable d'émettre des besoins parce que
écouter entendre les besoins de l'autre
c'est une chose mais toi capable
d'émettre tiens c'est compliqué faire
seule c'est compliqué même en être
conscient oui savoir exactement parce
que chaque fois que
met-on moi je me vois un mec mes besoins
puis j'ai l'impression la plupart du
temps quand j'en suis quand je le fais
dans lequel il faut les quelques fois je
les fais des
actifs it ça passe par ça passe par le
prisme de caisse que je pense que l'hôte
aimerait entend aussi tirer puis de
stanger là quand même conscient est en
train de dire ça passait vraiment ce qu
en train de dire ça parce que tu parles
si la bonne réponse sans guillemets pour
la conversation de temps ce primate pour
éviter un certain malaise ou un certain
inconfort peter raison la communication
c'est tellement la base de beaucoup de
satisfaction en relation c'est à dire
que plus s'exprimer besoins clairement
plus j'ai des chances de vendre aux
relations satisfaisant mais c'est pour
ça que j'aime beaucoup campent et les
dualités dans la dynamique parce que
comme tu dis est ce que j vraiment ce
que je pense ou j ce qu'il va faire
plaisir à l'autre c'est une dynamique
pour moi ce serait vraiment me
préoccuper des besoins de l'autre au
détriment des miens alors qu'on a
d'autres soucis pas du tout de ce que ça
va comme un pack plus comme le dépendant
qui lui nomme les affaires pleut il
réalise l'impact que ça le lac à partir
du moment où on aussi ses extrêmes
l'appui on sait sur quoi travailler on
peut faire un mi chemin parce qu on a
tous une tendance je suis qui se
préoccupe pas trop des autres et un dock
se préoccupe un peu trop de même mais
quand on fait le mi chemin puis qu'on se
parle c'est ce qu'ils rectifient pitot
raison à prendre un scanner ce soit les
gens je voudrais qu est ce que tu as
besoin ils savent pour qui c'est passé
c'est moi je considère qu'on est tous
des êtres intelligents on est tous des
gens sensibles mais on ne peu pris le
temps de s'asseoir ce qu'est ce que
j'aime pour vrai o'dowd j'aime la crama
savane et puis j'aime me faire la bise
clair tu sais comme qu'est ce que j'ai
envie de faire mais en relation sur la
même affaire le produit identifié un
besoin urgent eu le courage de le nommer
ouais le faut que j'aille la capacité
négocié allait commencer reçu puis je
viens juste de recevoir le besoin de
l'autre on ne touche pas la hauteur aux
pistes du corps et il veut toujours
ajouté que le tout paris sait il faut
être conscient ce soit je pense que
c'est la plus belle relation qu'on a
développés c'est d'abord comment ça
fonctionne le petit personnage que je
suis ses clients b parce qu'en
vieillissant on se rend compte qu'on
s'améliore on change pas la trame de
fond et pas mal parler comment qu'on le
découvre comment qu'on le trouve ce que
tu dis tu d'émana les exercices le
commandant se pose la question qu'est ce
que j'ai besoin qu est ce qui me rend
remous songe dit qu'est ce que tu as
mais faire quand tu étais petit c'est
passé les enfants qu'on a négligé parce
que c'est bon on n'avait pas le temps
c'était pour valoriser par notre famille
fait que non mais moi je mets se
dessiner tuez moi personnellement les
dessiner c'est pas quelque chose qui m'a
tuer meetic quand je regarde ce que je
fais comme moi je parte en vélo a manqué
mais j'étais encore de wang dit quand
j'ai besoin d'être seul avec moi je fais
des exercices au jeu marche puis à des
gens qui ont faire de l'or fait que
céder à des choses qui se sont exprimé
spontanément à l'enfance parce qu'il
fallait à l'école parce qu'on était
pressé parce qu'on avait pu exposer des
questions qu'est-ce que j'ai besoin qu
est ce qui me rend heureux
qu'est ce que je fais dans ma vie que et
quand je fais sur le ca me fait tomber
du bien sûr gardé au quotidien une fois
parce que c'était bon mais le fond
qu'est-ce qui est une femme je sais pas
c'est tellement irréel d'aller voir
dominique ph qui quoi oublier
sympathie c'est ce que je fais problème
il fait chaud je me sors tu sais c'est
pas compliqué l'environnement et feutrée
here i come see mais m'obliger à nommer
pour la pression est moche sens humain
qui fait chaud confortant quand ces
singes mais ça c'est des nations pour
moi fait que deux fois dans chaque
affaire qu'on fait ça nous aurait donc
s'observer exposé des questions mais
regardez qu'est ce qui nous des affaires
qu'on aime pas on n'aime pas on a tous
le droit
c'est tellement c'est tellement
pertinent son direct ce ça vient de
m'allumer quelque chose de prendre le
temps de mettons subi un soin aux
embauches par rapport à mai pourquoi une
faille en mettant le plextor la fin de
ce même des gamins se téléphonent ou
inversement et ça c'était c'était paul
von plus on pousse l'angle de sport
pourquoi tu serais capable de mettre le
doigt sur des enfants qui sont plaint
vraiment important ou important dans les
220 fonds pour toi puis des fois ça nous
permet d'observer
comment ça c'est super agréable puis
commence et tout était en place des
pôles forts à c'est peut-être moi qui
étais dans quel étage témoin avant de me
rendre nos podcasts
je pense que c'est en s'observant qui
donne souvent l'exemple de ceux qui ont
des enfants les gens qui ont des enfants
et ont des enfants extrêmement c'est
toujours les plus beaux et les plus
merveilleux et c'est vrai parce que le
regard qu'ils ont su re sic depuis
qu'ils sont tout petits il ya prés à
l'icône aide à comprendre comment
fonctionne qu est-ce que cet enfant
l'oeil heynckes kayem peau qu'est ce qui
lui convient il pleure pour six plans
pour ceux ci le même regard qu'il faut
faire sur son besoin d'artifices par
rapport aux autres pendant seulement
puis de regarder si ce camp qui m'ont
fait juste tourné deux fois le spot sur
ce camp mais qu'est ce qui était écrit
que tempo est certainement la belgique
mais c'est comme ça que ça quand même
pas si l'art des écritures c'est dans le
sens où on prend pu en fait on prend
plus on prend pas le temps face à jamais
c'est sympa si on l'a déjà pris mais moi
personnellement je le prends jamais elle
ne prend jamais le temps de six
d'analysé jeu en fait je pense que je
suis juste dans le
dans le centre si pige pas dans
l'analyse du cm oui ça peut commencer à
pâques acquis puis se jette dans le soin
comme exercice j'ai donné son intention
c'est mais aussi tous les jours de 10
aujourd'hui je me sens de tous et bien
marché pour
la journée d'après se fatiguer ou ben je
sais pas quel juif ou l'énervé puis y'a
pas de raison de tout ce que je trouvais
les prix mais pas de raison non plus
mais c'est pas grave ça me permet de
m'accompagner dans journée type de
acquis aujourd'hui je vis et que cette
motion la section des petits des petits
pots comme ce qui me permet
tranquillement de comprendre un peu plus
que marche fonctions puis après ça mais
c'est la même affaire pour l'autre est
trouvé avec qui ou l'aise au traitement
et que je partage mon quotidien puis
d'être juste dans l'accueil des fils
pour aujourd'hui au jour green bay wis
bagarre est une journée de mardi
dans l'émission
on a parlé tantôt doter le terme
dépendent encore des pandas revient
beaucoup
pour ceux qui ont qu'une
dizaine à une dualité les cinq secondes
la dualité et première un peu sans vraie
sainte et puis moi je me suis inspiré de
différents auteurs qui ont parlé de
chacune de ces duels taylor on les a
appelés des dualités dépendent encore
dépendants c'est la dualité première
parce qu'elle beaucoup représentatif de
l'attitude des gens par rapport au
quotidien par rapport à la vie par
rapport à tout ce qui se passe dans une
journée donc la dépendance justin est
foncièrement centré sur ces besoins qui
peut être très très égocentrique qui
préoccupe est d'abord parti pris à ses
propres besoins ses propres mal à s est
propre et adam il est naturellement je
mets un indépendant je présente dix
personnes il va s'associer naturellement
avec un codé pendant le coc dépendant
lui et préoccupés par les besoins des
hôtes avant ses propres besoins ça alors
généreux comme ça mes soins locaux
dépendant va se préoccuper des besoins à
son propre détriment tacle au début ça
va bien le département il ya des gros
besoins locaux d'épargnants prend soin
écoute fusion totale par moment donné
c'est comme le il ya comme une
expression de jeu puis capable parce que
ces comportements le ils sont
l'expression de besoins inassouvis
disconvient dit mon besoin hip hop
assouvi y est peu répandu fait que je
développe cette attitude est indépendant
il soit un show le
mécontent il dit haut et fort alors
qu'elle co dépendants et plus
enthousiaste toujours de bonnes mans est
toujours sensible que l'environnement
soit horreur de ça sa cause est clos le
défi c'est de voir difficulté un tout
petit dans les deux adultes est ce que
le godet paris exprime ses besoins
naturellement librement sans aucune
retenue
la difficulté du codépendance locaux
dépendant lui très sensible aux autres
waouh l'on va faire les deux on est
sensible aux besoins de l'homme qui en
expriment nos besoins parce que le coût
dépendance pas vrai que tout est
toujours merveilleux extraordinaire il
ya le droit de lui aussi de aya matin là
j'suis matin guy et souris je resterais
chez nous tranquille j'ai pas le goût
d'y aller juste ça permet seule
codépendance un défi à la dépendance et
comme c'est une journée sans chez all
ages on essaye arrive dans mon bus
roulent on l'a le fauteuil plus
confortable
puis le son bain et du stationnement
plus comment il fait juste mais aussi je
sais déjà que ces indépendants les coûts
dépendants ils me demandent comment
chevaux avant de commencer leur entrevue
il fait que c'est magnifique lors du bal
thé tech tout les duels t on un pôle
poursuivre un pôle négatif mais ayant
des caractéristiques et des forces
contrat pour en faire le michalek soit
celles dépendantes ou dépendant beaucoup
l'attitude général par rapport à la vie
juste rapidement avant qu'on souhaite
aux autres est ce que en fait je pense
que je pense que tu le disais dansions
s'aimer mais
est ce que 2 dépendant pour être
ensemble puis rester
sur leur nature de dépendance ou bang
comme tu dis je pense y en a un qui
tombe dans l'autre c'est incompatible de
personnes qui qui seraient dans la même
dualité il s'attire pas si ce système de
dépendance sont centristes le groupe
besoin personnes peuvent faire le lien
entre les deux les deux coups d'epernay
vont se chamailler pour pallier la
facture faire les choses de prendre soin
des cas on a deux duels tes semblables
généralement il y en a qui tombe dans
dépendance ou d'un coup dépendance où la
relation aura pas lieu mais
naturellement les gens ils s'attirent
lors du maltais contrat mais de toujours
ont plus que l'autre toi et que la
dynamique devient ce ouest les gens vous
aiment et montrer que je suis capable
monde entier dépendant codépendance et
peut-être pas leur dualité dominant
parce que si on a un dôme nash à côté
mais des duels txcom ah oui ça c'est
vraiment notre l'autre du ltc et motifs
rationnels soit c'est vraiment la
dualité de la communication les motifs
temps être intérieur il sent les
affaires il y vit très intuitif et très
perspicace marche au félin mais quand
vient le temps de le mettre en mots il
ya peu de vocabulaire puisse pas
quelqu'un qui s'exprime beaucoup les
ventes de deux trois mots que ça veut
dire suffisamment ce que ça veut dire
avec un rationnel qui marche au fait où
statistique d'où vient l'information qui
quittent sur explique moi sur par mois
sonné de beaucoup de mots mais qui à
l'inversé du mal à regarder comme un
simple que la dualité pareil les motifs
apprend au rationnel comme médecin quand
rationnelle du commun sans il est
beaucoup moins de mots qui les motive
mais après qu'ils aient dit deux ou
trois mots c'est déjà applaudissons
situation parce que c'est un dépassement
mais sont les meilleurs professeurs le
dos parce que le rationnel eu beaucoup
de mots en banque pour les motifs puis
les motifs il est en train d'apprendre
rationnelle qu'avec peu de mots on peut
dire la même chose mais c'est beaucoup
au niveau de la communication que ça va
accrocher les gérants des trois manches
à me perdre beaux lots la goutte à
goutte
c'est beaucoup la communication ensuite
on a actifs rêveur se sait dans le
quotidien c'est dans toutes les tâches à
faire l'actif les fait le ménage puis
faisceau dans l'ordre ont fait le lavage
on lave on sèche on plie orange révolue
et partir de brosser les dents à partir
d'une date je m'en fous bien répondu au
téléphone puis faire d'autres choses
parce que ces moments là sont importants
fait que l'actif est beaucoup dans la
tâche avant de s'abandonner leur
évoluent et profitons de la vie on
passera aux responsabilités plus tant
pis dans un coup mais c'est toujours
aussi un conflit dans ce sens que aux
noms ont beau pour ce match samedi
après-midi affaire d'état mais il faut
que ça se fasse qui vont répondre même
temps comme pas l' équilibre on est
responsable on a des tanches mon oubli
pour profiter de la vie prendre le temps
de saluer le matin et s'embrassent et
puis d'écouter en facilement dans notre
société ça m'a tellement 200 milliards
on est juste dans l'attachement de
responsabilité puisse parfois mais c'est
ça mais inversement s'il ya des tâches
doivent être faites comme ses fils et
soler 6e la complémentarité doigt et il
comme un quart dans lesquels on a des
tas la même année il faut faire
l'épicerie vont faire le lavage actifs
qui peuvent
non mais c'est ben oui petite larme à
toute évidence
oui voilà il faut que ça fonctionne oui
parce que dans les extrêmes le rêveur il
peut procrastiner sur ses tâches et les
conséquences qu'il y en avait avec un
actif qui dit oui métier tout est
toujours ça finit jamais la moins qu'en
mangeant des belles social de carton
piqués on se promène en pyjama toute la
journée on a toujours du lavage vous
l'avez sur la fin avec s'arrête jamais
l'état il faut être capable de hockey le
principal effet allons nous amuser à
l'on sait profiter de la vie
fusionner un solitaire
beaucoup l'intimité relationnel beaucoup
l'intimité sexuelle le défi pour refuser
la salt à
préserver mes besoins personnels tout en
m'occupant des besoins du couple soit
les copies finissent par parler au nom
et puis de jeu on est allé le on a dit
celui-ci se répondre pour l'autre il
parle au nom de l'homme ccdh et
fusionner les soldats ce que je trouve
bizarre une journée tout seul et oui
pourquoi tu sentais pas bien avec non
c'est ma page pas bien avec vous le
secteur a besoin de temps seul ou youri
et en affaires il restera poneys sont
pas passifs dans le fond du vent mais
ils vont organiser sa journée un peu à
sa guise il ya surtout besoin de se
réaliser dans tous les domaines de sa
vie pour mieux revenir dans la relation
peut être disponible alors qu'elles
fusionnaient les besoin d'être bien en
relation pour avoir l'énergie pour aller
se réalise et andorre la relation se ça
permet des clips où j'ai deux individus
qui évolue tout en donnant du temps la
relation de
ces choses là j'imagine que est ce que
dans le fond chaque personne au s2
toutes ces dualités chaque personne a
une des caractéristiques de la duel
poing factice pas être indépendant
rationnelle vite fusionnelle et le
dernier non le moindre ça va tellement
banal mais c'est le viet et le lin c'est
dans un cas quelqu'un quatre ans le bord
de la pop qui tape du pied parce que
l'autre est peu près tout y est pas prêt
ce sacré des conflits lé jeu sans
rentrer dans mon bureau il y en a un qui
arrive artop le vix est en mode ip ce
qu'a toujours en retard c'est leur
première rencontre le choisit bon ça y
est les autres le seul conflit au lieu
de partir avec garnier l'a bien vu
l'important c'est qu'on soit lu comme un
conte à 12h05 de retomber le vide il
fait tout ville il parle vite réagi vite
et prend des décisions vite il fait le
ménage uteq il pu laisser sentiment de
bousculer le lent mais le lay est
toujours bush lui ça va toujours trop
vite pour lui c'est les jambes on doit
ne pas de vol à prendre y a pas
d'urgence est pas mort d'homme c'est pas
grave c'est vrai ce jour un peu comme on
dit en taule équilibre ok moi c'est
important d'être à l'heure d'être
ponctuel du petit organe de partir un
peu plus tôt porsche et que je sois pas
l'impression que c'est moi qui le
bousculent pour arriver en forme au même
profil
c'est un fait tellement rire parce que
évidemment ce que tu dis est tout le
temps ouais se passa ses mois ça c'est
moi mais c'est cesser dans tout les
dualités dans toutes les coupes dans
toutes les relations figure au travail
c'est la même affaire et janis associe
effectué tu travailles avec un associé
il y avait un échange tout à fait le
contraire de toi mais en même temps
c'est ça la magie c'est comme acquis lui
sa force et sa moi c'est ce comment on
fait pour se respecter dans nos
différences avant de communication des
actions
des responsabilités qui sont bien gérées
mais dans le respect de tout le monde
parce que faut faire le michelin jusque
deux extrêmes et là on reste une
opposition sacré des malades et des
conflits juste par rapport à vite lampy
c'est dans le fond c'est quoi la
différence avec actifs rêvent ensemble
oui tu as raison c'est que le rêveur
pile actifs et à leur actif ils bougent
pas cité ses tâches en tout la vitesse
n'est pas vraiment important mais il pas
bien d'aller ces foires est dans le vin
coûte une émission télé que son amoureux
6 l de vin qui traînent dans la boue
faut tout tout tout tout tout soit fait
mais tout tout tout n'étant pas une
réalité pas possible ça fait ça
hypothèque le temps de qualité le rêveur
et des xylophones en fin de semaine on
n'a pas les enfants on va pouvoir en
profiter puis elle ou lui au prix prévu
de rencontrer les feuilles allait
changer la musique en est on pour la
même vision fait que vous écoutez le
rêveur pour être disponible émotivement
la relation alors que le vide et là
c'est le rythme est dans le quotidien le
vide d'ici là le café fait la douche est
fait à partir de barcelone un bon matin
ça vaut l'axé beaucoup dans la vitesse
puis le rêveur puis le verser dans
l'application des temps c'est que comme
père disait c'est quand qu'on explique
sa sexualité le conte est écrit
inévitablement on se reconnaît dans
certaines très choqués les jambes jeune
fugueuse monde qui ont écouté le dernier
quinze minutes qui ont les yeux comment
ça va lancer des bons sujets comme un
jeu mais une fois qu'on sait ce nouveau
concert un peu plus qu'elle
quelle base quelles caractéristiques on
a été con et qu'est ce qu'on fait qu'est
ce qu'on fait mais ton mais j'imagine ça
mais c'est une très bonne question
maintenant je t'ai indépendant j'étends
700 après sur moi ma job c'est de faire
l'exercice parce que ce pas naturel puis
soit parce que c'est pas naturel que je
n'aime pas les gens avec qui j'ai évolué
mais ce pont naturel en nature et sauna
préoccuper de man avec l'indépendant
maintenant qu'ils s'identifient comme
indépendants c'est faire l'exercice
l'effort de me soucier des autres
davantage les codépendance on leur dit
la prends soin de toi d'abord le coup
d'épargné prend soin de lui ou elle il
sent coupable le codé par l'indépendant
il prend soin des autres un moment donné
revient sa forme est à partir du code et
pendant ce prioriser dépendant prioriser
les ans la ville les fautes choisi
le père dans ce we seek maintenant moi
je
me dirais des pandas maintenant et dans
dance lens mais le pire c'est que si
j'étais avec quelqu'un qui va prendre
une maintenant cliquer qui connaît pas
la même taille mais qui va prendre le
travail de prendre du temps pour elle
oui ben moi ça je vais être content de
ça me tombe et savons faire plaisir que
cette personne n'en ait compte ses
comptes qui fait habituellement pour
s'occuper d'elle même temps je dois
faire mes affaires de mon bord la presse
au pica avec ben correct le tiff est
souvent le travail que tu fais
surtout av bob automatiquement plaire à
l'autre de faire du bien à l'autre même
si ces complémentarités pour mais parce
que ça encourage locaux dépendant
prendre soin de lui qui naturellement se
sent coupable de le faire le dépendant
il se rend compte que et quand je me
soucie des autres c'est dans my phone ça
fait plaisir mais ça me fait plaisir
aussi claire est quelque chose qui
s'enchaînent quand on se retrouve à
mi-chemin goethe identifient comme
invite toujours
rétrogradé la visite la bise fds ça va
toujours trop vite si c'est qu'en fait
quand arrêter ou des folies cliente ait
beaucoup question dans même franchement
mesures monge et byte loader luis a pas
de bon sens mais je suis d'école et
curieuse pis les lacets comme ok c'est
pas lui c'est pas la situation c'est pas
le contexte sainte aux jo bush qui lie
prato d'avant
c'est papa derniers mois c'est un vote
et un gros 10 minutes un groupe d'une
minute pour le virus et des genres tort
comme moi juste à chisinau je me prends
d'avant sommes sentis bousculé je suis
vite je ralentis parce que je toujours
trop d'impôts d'avant actifs rêva est-ce
important que la vaisselle dans le
lavabo soit directement mis dans le lave
vaisselle ou détriment de mes enfants de
mon amoureuse de mon amoureux qui me
réclame du temps
leur est versé comme il vit dans la
tempe il ya toujours espoir de quelque
chose 2010 pour être leur est versé ce
week-end j'aimerais ça qu'on prenne ce
temps sans j'aimerais ça que les
responsabilités là mais on les facile ça
fait plaisir mais que samedi après midi
ses notes après me dis je revends à
personne oui pas de problème c'est juste
de le nommer oui parce que le rêve à sa
votre soin lui il faut profiter de la
ville c'est banal responsable il nomme
peu
émotif mais des mots mais omis cycle
annonce
par les écoutes et matifie par canton et
laisse du temps non pas que c'est comme
maintenant que je m'identifie je fais un
pas en direction de la [ __ ] la wimax
dans le fond que le but c'est d'être
un peu le plus possible dans le milieu
du spectre de cette dualité le but c'est
l'autonomie affective parce que ce cd
des manifestations que j'ai développée
par incapacité de voir à mes besoins là
bas où j'ai dû la petite heure de
comportements qui ont fonctionné ça fait
comme un breton je tâte du pi puis je
veux ça répond contenu et moi mes
besoins alors pas important mais quand
je m'occupe des autres ça me fait du
bien je veux le faire que ça fonctionne
et ça fonctionne plus avec le but le
mi-chemin il me permet de juger des
besoins j'ai des limites j'ai des
inconforts je les nomme on est entre
nous on se respecte qui ont fait quelque
chose de constructif ont fait équipe on
est ensemble pour créer quelque chose
parce que ta défense extrêmement qui
sont mes faiblesses et vice versa on
voir le meilleur des deux sexes et
l'autonomie effective dans le fond du
puits est ce que les dualités c'est tout
le temps par rapport
cite un absolu au soudan par rapport à
l'autre tu remets ton par rapport à
quelqu'un d'autre tout parce que tout le
temps je suis les dépendants de cette
relation là où juste je suis dépendant
reçu des parents et qui fait clair il
fait pas beau le jeu tout au bout parce
qu'il fait jamais bouclé par la
dépendance il moussavi est seul dans son
univers est contrarié et puis il ya des
malaises qui est envahi par les
accessoires qui se rend comme un être
humain en l'occurrence un coude et
pendant qu'ils écoutent ça devrait me
nomme marc savard croit tout va sortir
et elle qu'au départ dans ce cas est qui
et qui aurait besoin et c'est vrai il
faudrait que il cherche toujours à
assouvir l'eau merci beaucoup mais est
ce que je pourrais mettront être
dépendants dans ma relation de couple
mais le cours des parts dans ma relation
d'affaires excellente question oui parce
que dans différents domaines je peux
changer de son côté panda partout sont
très fatigués et avec sont dépendants
partout ils sont trés envahi par le
besoin mais effectivement il y en a en
relation amoureuse ils sont dépendants
mais à leur travail sont codées panda
avec son visage avec sa départ équité
jumelées et aider votre pool choix
d'amener des gens par exemple sont très
émotifs qui sont l'un médicaments votre
travail et le cas match de simple à
l'intense pas très encouragé des coûts
travail sont très efficaces sont très
productifs mais dans la vie quand ils
peuvent se le permettre leur nature
profonde réapparait fait que oui on peut
changer tout dépendant du contexte dans
lequel je suis puis tout dépendant de la
dualité dans laquelle je négocie que les
autres aient trouvé auto vous la mesure
à la plupart c'est pas clair pour moi
mettons de quel bord aux big three je me
trouve un cadeau des pandas co dépendant
maintenant je taille de rapidement nous
sommes bien battus tout aussi clair pour
tous ben moi moi tu pour moi vis-à-vis
moi c'est extrêmement gros que toi c'est
facile à stocker non mais c'est vrai
retour que toi c'est comme tu dit ce
monsieur est peut-être que toi ça varie
selon favorisés seront là ça va je sais
pas qui c'est je suis moyenne en quote
part
qu'il est préoccupé par tes besoins les
besoins des autres je dirais mes besoins
ok dépendants est ce que tu es en vie
tout en un
je dirais vite parce que les chauffards
le plus d'affaires possible
des matières au rationnel c'est un homme
de beaucoup de mots ou toulouse mais je
ne dirais pas vite aussi clairement
exclu se mettant ses parents mettons
concon confort d'une place pitt encore
une brosse à dents d'embauché avec genre
en train de finir de 3 à faire parce que
c'est à cause des seuils définir du trot
affable ce que je vais faire un
choix je vais vraiment justes ou en
retard mais à cause que ouais faut que
je pense que plus de choses
étaient que ça prend là finalement way
[Rires]
c'est irrationnel et matières bain
certaines personnes dire m et tomba
blonde direct chez motif puis demandez
qui je travaille qui dirait que je suis
rationnelle ratio n'est fait on est
mature qui fait 50 à faire en même temps
ouais il se brosse les dents puis cech
un peu nouvelle puisque toyota fort puis
ça tout ça vient de lever entre allons
aussi méritant un lent parce que tu
marche au feeling du web soit aménagé
dans bas des dossiers ouverts c'est
qu'en fait c'est cela c'est ce qui me
confirme gâter leurs enfants parce que
c'est quand même enfin aux pilotes un
typé bonhomme rouge sang puis j'ai un
mot et son running a pris 95 c'est messi
parce que tout marche au feeling tactile
et
matif l'un et quoi d'autres actifs rêve
il est quand même je travaille peut-être
qui est différent non mais même même des
quand même rationnelle mais je pense que
tu ton rationnel qui parle pas trop long
de ses émotions mais tombe c'est la
dualité rationnelle et motifs le tti
vraiment rationnelles sont ils paient
d'affaires de com était super cartésien
sur mettons les études ces choses là
puis la science petit truc là sauf que
sauf que tu dis parle pas de tes
émotions vraies non plus puisqu'ils sont
relatés émotions pour toi
jusque là comment tu samatan sont
incapables de le nommer
ouais mais c'est assez
ça c'est également ce que
c'est rare qu'une journée je veux
vraiment triste ou
nourrissent pas nécessairement dans
l'expression mais c'est parce que
probablement lui doit au niveau du
travail peut-être que nous va mourir
qui sait peut-être c'est acté champs
d'intérêt qui sont très cartésien et
intellectuel mais en fait en relation
qu'un petit exprime est ce que tu est un
homme de peu de mots août est un être
qui s'expriment librement et facilement
c'est le symbole de terminer sur un axe
central de brume en effet seulement
hockey fact et plus rationnel enfants
les rationnels ils sont très sensibles
c'est pas irrationnel pas des pierres
protégeant votre carte c'est juste que
quand il s'exprime c'est des mots qui
sortent haut lieu soit une émotion
ta classe à taichung le seul
fait qu'un départ non rationnel un ouais
c'est quoi qui reste actif rêveur dit en
arrivant un amoureux à la va vite
qu'est-ce qui a fusionné salt à thème se
passer du temps qu'aucun et/ou thèmes
plus faire tout à fait pour rentrer à la
maison peut être content de retrouver
table on
juge caricature rapidement la maison
mais
ça c'est pas de la
tarte avec ma blonde je suis très
présent oui mais on peut être des longs
bouts de cet ensemble si tout est bien
parce que tu trialisant ta job on voit
tes amis tu vois ta famille tu as des
activités bien neuf à ses enfants de six
mois mais c'est principalement le
premier point la job les amis de paris
ses moindres exemple mais moi c'est
surtout ce fait qu'un telle ou telle
hommes et femmes sont réalisés les
autres domaines de tête parfait affecte
pas avoir le même plus un seul tu as
mais quand et le thé le jeu
tout en observant des caractéristiques
des dualités ses classes comme hors
marché vraiment indépendant il ya des
couples même moi j'arrive pas à cerner
c'est quoi mais clairement ils sont des
vieux et des lampes sol ça crée des
problèmes dans tous les domaines de la
vie il ya un accès et motifs rationnels
et chicanes dans mon bureau plus
explosif mais les autres ce n'est pas
que la fed prendra qu'une dualité qui
est dominant on devrait être capable de
se retrouver un peu d'enjeu sortir parce
que tu sais j'ai lu en fait le tour on
doit être tournée qui dit j'avais des
points que je me reconnais cette fournée
de côté et puis c'est peut-être rêvera
c'est un peu plus tôt l'armée si c'était
quand même rare que je me disais ça
c'est vraiment moi je suis vraiment
extrêmes ce way tandis que je me disais
de faux php extrême c'est important mais
ce n'est même pas ça même pas difficile
à trouver mais à faire des tirs puis le
père moi mais tintin en entendant tout
tous contre combat le put antho
bienveillant expérimenté soit aussi dans
plusieurs relations et plusieurs
relations denses dans quelques relations
ce qui crée les conflits au final
c'est souvent une différence
du moins de mon expérience et des
différences maintenant que je capable de
nommer m grâce à ce qu'on vienne parler
le ouais sauf qu'ils sont tellement
c'est tellement d des petites affaires
qui dans la grande échelle de la vie
sont parfois importantes c'est juste
juste le mais c'est souvent comme ça au
péage déjà mise et on sait pas nier le
fait trois jours qu'on est là tu es
souvent il se rappelle même pas pourquoi
pas ça a déclenché une banalité que
déclencher quelque chose à l'intérieur
de soi mais souvent c'est comme ça
peut-être même l'accumulation des jarres
banalité parce qu'il est on parle de
actifs erévan
je suis vraiment plus actifs le team et
ont
juste l'exemple de la vaisselle c'est
l'exemple la plus connue au monde entier
parce que c'est tellement bénin c'est
tellement minime sauf que je peux même
pas compter avec les mêmes admis dix
doigts le nombre de fois où est ce que
c'est devenu un enjeu ça passait deux
doigts j'ai passé 2
j'ai passé doivent compter le nombre de
fois que c'est devenu un enjeu est dans
une relation si comme on laisse faire ça
oui ça existe souvent là gisait à ses
actifs non pour ne pas désespérer a été
si j'étais le dernier moment que table
on est ensemble soit en vouloir qu'elle
a pris la vaisselle prioriser mais
l'actif y est vraiment là il est bien
qu'un tout tout tout est fait capable
d'imposer ses seins sitôt des prophètes
s'expose si l'édifice et de se poser
même si les jeux ne sont pas faits
s'active quand on utilisait dans qu'est
ce qu'on fait mais on voit l'enfance et
se briser le parton comment naturel
c'est que les choses sont faites quand
sont en fait je peux me déposer c'est
moi on est stressé que je pense 52 aussi
projetant un peu roches et j'arrive à
dernière minute qui ont fait les choses
différemment puis le sait ce que c'est
pas naturel
c'est quand contre nature mais en même
temps ça donne des résultats levant que
l'on finit par équilibre un peu la fin
est ce qu'on prend c'est mettons
justement tu étais vraiment d'un côté je
comprends d'où peut venir l'attirance
pour quelqu'un qui est différente oui
que justement ça un complément sa
complémentaire t'impressionne même
technique capable d'être super rêveur
qui capable d'être super ces méthodes
tout était introverti l'okapi s'exprime
tout beau tout ça mais au final ça peut
aussi être ça vaut
pas causer lucile fans parce qu'on a un
regard d'ouverture et d'accueil même
année la dualité à prend trop de place
dans sa lettre le temps de négocier le
kiki qui a raison le célèbre faut quand
même faire preuve d'ouverture dans la
différence de l'autre comprendre l'autre
comme il se comprend puis après ce avec
apparemment une conversation c'est pour
ça que j'aime bien parler du rituel
amoureux ou voulu que ce soit tout
moment dans la journée puis on
s'accroche on accumule on est pleinement
du prophète pas le point deux fois par
soi même on est début de notre relation
on est dans des day tenait du funk et
oui on a ri disposer fraîchement douche
et de bonne humeur on est heureux de
foule enthousiaste on est parfumé au
patois pis là on est surtout avant tout
en donnant des exemples un peu extérieur
mais intérieurement ce comme j'ai hâte
j'ai hâte de savoir comment tu vaux pour
vrai un agneau le parquet ce canton dans
le quotidien pendant nos responsabilités
facteurs juste avant le rituel comment
ça se passe pour toi cette semaine du
jour en dehors de faut pas oublier
d'aller faire les courses ou aller
chercher la luge pour enfin de sa mère
d'aller chez les beaux parents
commencent pissos mais ça permet de
faire le point puis des prêts dans des
extrêmes comme ceux accumulés d'audition
et ses deux comme cette semaine j'ai
juste fait de quoi qui te dirai ça y est
tu est quelque chose qui est accroché où
tout est beau comment là
j'ai déjà eu des jets déjà voulu prendre
un moment pour faire une d'être dans une
relation de longue haleine fait de faire
qui nous ont fait au moins une babe
barcelone a fait naître au restaurant se
gardent retard et vos restes au pis et
les préoccupations
si les gros baptisé les préoccupations
du quotidien qui deviennent le sujet de
conversation tout c'est pas vraiment les
individus tués puis le ca fait la bête
et comme gauche et d'un garçon on serait
resté chez nous on aurait fait la même
chose qu'on fait tout le temps parce que
c'est pas aller dans l'état où je pense
que c'était une première beit l'on se
parle pas d'eux notamment ces
changements d'aujourd'hui était si
c'est quand même assez l'exercice et
comment on se préoccupe de comment on
vit comment ça c'est comme tu dis tu es
tu déranges été tuerie t ou au pis voit
au contraire ça peut être un système
s'est vraiment en forme c'est le camp tu
te fait telle chose autorités là dessus
ça m'a tellement fait du bien quand as
tu citais la france ça m'a tellement
sociaux passent à côté de s'arrêter deux
est donc bien agréable que si elle me
dit ces dons mais il fonde le regard que
tu poses sur moitié parce que s'arrêtait
pour ce faire une mise à jour c'est
aussi faire la mise à jour par la police
il fait peu
mais c'est mais est-ce qu'au final tu
étudies justement les deux côtés d'une
dualité vont s'attirer mais on est ce
qu'on n'est pas mieux de trouver
quelqu'un qui est plus proche de nous au
niveau des dualités pour qu'il y ait
moins d'accrochages qu'on soit plus
pareil sur premafin
l'eau il faut être pareil puisque moi ce
que je constate c'est naturellement les
dualités satire
professionnellement amicalement
amoureusement mais ce qu'il faut que ce
soit pareil s'élève à laon les intérêts
les activités son sens au report on peut
pas aller dans des dualités où on est en
conflit mais quand les valeurs les
externes au dualité dans le fond ouais
c'est ça kalevala les intérêts les
activités sont sensiblement commune ben
j'ai j'ai le goût de comprendre l'autre
comment est ce qu'on prend j'ai le goût
d'apprendre à voir comment ça fonctionne
qui copie si je comprends cette
différence le qui nous unit mais en même
temps qu'il nous dise temps ci mais si
comme je me suis sentie coupable facile
demain mouche je le comprends pas du
tout comment ce phénomène est tolérée
par rapport à 11 par
ok cela permet de comprendre pourquoi
cette hormone est important que tout
soit fait pour toi parce que
l'import d'accès pas tant le
comportement que qu'est ce qu'ils soient
bien parce que c'est sur l'autonomie
effective c'est ok tu toi pour être
bientôt besoin de sous je publie de
comprendre je peux juste comprendre que
pour toi c'est important sont en
approche de noël bon c'est important
pour eux je peux juste con franchement
même pas obligé d'avoir la même ampleur
est important pour tous parce que je me
soucie t besoin on va aller dans une
direction plus a adouci te il ya une
limite au compromis qu'une personne peut
faire tirer dessus à marne est tellement
aller loin dans le comprendre l'autre
que keats que c'est rolls et une écoute
plus toi moi maintenant ben oui puisse
une limite c'est quelque chose qui se
ressent ce pas quelque chose qui se
décide à nîmes istres intérieure taxes
hossa se définit par chacun des
individus c'est clair que curieux de
l'abus il ya de la violence c'est
tolérance zéro
mais si quand on a l'impression qu'on
est allé au bout de quelque chose qui
qu'on est seul dans la démarche je donne
tu vas quand tu rentres dans un canot tu
tournes en rond
quand on atteint cette limite je pense
qu'il faut la nommer faut l'exprimer
comment j'ai l'impression que tu es allé
au bout de mes capacités
en fait qui pourraient être des
solutions où ça s'arrête mais ces
intérieurs fait que c'est la personne
qui elle-même a décidé à je suis capable
d'aller au bout ça fait non emmené dans
sa fesse d'asepsie après trois semaines
trois mois trois ans 13 ans ça c'est
l'individu qui désire t il faut être
dans le respect de soi même puis c'est
parce que vous êtes attentif comment je
me sens chantraine dépasser mes limites
ça c'est le défi souvent de certains
individus en sont toujours en
dépassement mais à lui est le propre des
crimes
est-ce que des fois
mais je dois parler de manque
d'expérience mais on dirait que je suis
inévitablement attiré par
des personnes que non mais par le fesf
par la capacité d'ouvrir et par le même
type de personne oui si les patrons des
personnes souvent qui quand qu'on garde
les dualités son extrême à l'extrême de
ma dualité à moins qu'à chaque fois que
je sors de ses relations le jeu me
disent tout le temps à la prochaine fois
le ne ferez pas prendre je me ferais pas
prendre je je je veux prendre quelqu'un
qui est maintenant que je le nomme mais
je voudrais pas de même à ce moment là
mais je vais prendre quelqu'un qui est
dans mes dualité parce que le super ça
c'est impossible puis j'ai l'impression
que c'est ça que je veux mais
inévitablement
suppose pas vers l'autre je vais
automatiquement tic tac à lui de
travailler sur repérer la bonne personne
aucune offre pour vivre sans toi
d'emblée quand t'es laissé dans une
nouvelle relation travail tout de suite
la dépendance le rationnel celui qui
veut que tout soit fait face à va
désamorcer parce que un jour il à haute
voix c'est ce qui arrive moi c'est ça
que travailler sur chaque site fait tout
tout tout tout à tuer quelqu'un
graphique attaque défini mais si tu dis
ok - sur simon pierre charrier jeunesse
le social choisi fait que sort n'a plus
de pouvoir - les pressions qu'ont subis
les choix qu'on fait qui naturellement
si charte de mon extrême de la dualité
j'attire l'autre affaire à mi-chemin sa
désamorcer un peu plus ce soit ou les
deux manches en train de choisir la
bonne personne de la bonne on n'a pas de
contrôle il ya mille et une façons que
si duhalt lots s'exprime il est patent
c'est ça c'est mince on travaille très
fort pour cela tirer c'est comment je
vais faire la différence dans mes
attitudes que je vais avoir des
meilleurs résultats parce que c'est vrai
que ceux ci c'est clair que si tu fais
un chemin pour que ça fonctionne faut
que la personne façon un jour aussi très
flexible xt commence par faire le chemin
doit même chose qu'il avait désamorcé de
l'autre côté ouais c'est que tu sais
c'est live chewing gums et authenticité
départ dames et j'appréhende
interrelations tu es plus qu dépendre
de celui qui s'occupe de l'autre le
terrible coup le qui donne
non
ben non je pense pas que je fais
attention à l'eau nécessaire mais je
pense que
je vois ta réflexion ainsi que des
dépendances ils sont très gentils d'en
prendre soin des eaux mais la motivation
est pas là même qu un codé pendant un
coût des pandas est vraiment gentil
naturellement sans compter sans attente
etc au départ notre gentil il fait un
peu pour son propre bénéfice et azy
saydon de la reconnaissance et ça fait
du bien et que ça nourrit encore ses
besoins avec des fois c'est vrai que
c'est plus discret que je les perçois
était peut-être un peu dans cette
catégorie lot moi c'est plus mes besoins
avant sur des
noms mais pas par rapport à ceux ci ou
100 % des voix le chat qui me prend soin
quand même des hommes et c'est pour son
propre bénéfice
mais c'est qu'après ça je pense qu'il
faut pour pas mélanger un serment ce
avec
actes versus rêveur ou active à faire
des actions mettons au quotidien qui
sont pas nets qui prend soin de l'autre
mais dans le fond team et on prend soin
de lui faire le lunch le mettons pour
pour le couple qui sépare la cuisine
mettons la main c'est qu'elle est une
tâche il faut qu'ils se fassent le
nécessaire mais pas nécessairement par
un nom exact c'est sa structure je le
peux pas nécessairement par altruisme de
vouloir c'est ça combler un besoin
d'autres personnes maintenant je pense
mais maintenant avec rim ccc ses fils et
fascinant honnêtement je suis sûr que si
ce presque dans un processus sans fin
c'est ce qu'il sait sur qui est
fascinant parce que on évolue comme je
disais tantôt donc mes besoins changent
il ya des besoins qu'on a à certaines
paires de novik sont non négociables
mais ça fait et c'est porteur d'espoir
grave aujourd'hui c'est plus ce qui est
sûr c'est qu'il faut toujours être
attentif à soit parce que des fois on
reste pris sur 10 situation d attente
puis dans le fond c'est ce que c'est
vraiment ce que soit ma sexualité que ce
soit le type de relation amoureuse que
je veux c'est même si je suis dans la
même relation où j'ai différentes
relations faut juste toujours s'assurer
que notre relation évolue en fonction
des nouveaux besoins puis des besoins de
l'autre puis ce qu'ils font c'est que
c'est un processus sans fin les
personnes qui ont besoin moi je suis
arrivé à l'apogée de mes besoins
justement pleinement et naturellement et
non parce que ça change de métier il ya
des besoins que ce prix aurait il pris
soin d'inviter jean ferrat qui ont
travaillé un besoin puisque lors les
autoroutes on veut tout leur est reconnu
être mais est l'irb éthiques vous aimez
ces quelques il plus important cette
étape ci ne
puis au retour par les patterns
justement habiter dans l'émission aussi
il sera question de défaire les parties
commencent conséquent par tonne est
négatif mais tant pis comment comment
qu'on le fait pour le travailler là
dessus un patent d'une blessure à la
base un bateau c'est un comportement
répétitif que j'utilise pour contourner
une blessure c'est à dire qu'il ya une
émotion que j je développe un
comportement sa fille que j'ai des
mécanismes de défense et des attitudes
défense et le jeu prudemment par tonne
mes besoins restent inassouvi plus drôle
alors on le sait que ce n'est pas tout
puisque c'est ce frein j'ai toujours la
même blessure qui est déclenché mon lieu
de je me sens racheter je me sens seule
je me sens pas entendu j'adopte un
comportement action réaction on le sait
déjà que ça va donner ça veut dire il
l'est au lieu de fin action réaction ce
qui naturellement l'inter de mois
inscrits canche en relation pour sa
blessure là où ce malaise est accroché
le cheval nommé je me suis sentie
rejetée je m'ennuie c'est inconfortable
je sais ce que ça veut pas dire que
l'autre la responsabilité de répondre
aux besoins mais moi je viens de sortir
de mon mécanisme qui fait que je
toujours dans un affaire action réaction
sans en plus n'avoir jamais satisfaction
montbozon avec le nommé l'exprimer puis
aussi voir comment moi je peux répondre
à ce besoin d'eux pour juste l'autre
personne moi j'ai une responsabilité
aussi de ma mère dans des environnement
sécurisant où je suis reconnue ou goethe
apprécier ou pas ce qu'elle parte o'neal
suit partout la sexy je me sens d'une
telle façon de façon un confort temps
c'est comme je considère que dans tous
les devants dans ma vie aux rixes m
suite mais c'est un fait ça me suis
comment moi je peux faire pour aller
dans des besoins satisfaisant c'est par
exemple les gens qui sont dans le rejet
on traverse une contraire j'ai pu me
sentir acheter méchant défi ok je me
sentir reconnu ses seuls contrats ou y
qui m'a aidé à me sentir reconnus qui
m'a aidé à me sentir bien soit c'est
inconfortable on n'est pas habitué on
n'est plus dans un jeu l'enregistrement
ça fonctionne jusqu'au mariage et puis
quand même défendre plus dans le
registre juste merci juste recevoir
pineau on développe la capacité de vivre
dans un environnement qui répond plus à
ses besoins jusque là oui je vais
même plus comme ce taudis tiff kelly
j'imagine ça ça aide de comprendre d'où
qu'ils proviennent pas retenu non sens
que si bien dévié d'une blessure
comprendre seco tablent sur le style en
france tous les parents ça peut aider
médias partir du moment où la blessure
est le leur et j'aime ça fait la même
cellule mais la gravure à la synergie
afin que les gens que ce pas
nécessairement important pour eux chez
moi comme je travaille pas
nécessairement dans toute la
reconstruction mais plus de
l'accompagnement éducatif comme
encaissés sur table et sur ton besoin
contraire 7 2 sur le seul à vauvert ces
situations le voir ces individus va vers
ses environnements l'eau ou du sang
reconnu aimer apprécié c'est un défi en
soi parce qu'on saxon est très longtemps
je joue en train d'en faire plus que les
autres j'étais présent que je mets à
pops comme on déjà vu c'est ça le
partage pas c'est inévitable mais ce qui
est possible de changer ces cas manquer
moi je m'en sors de logements les
affaires j'ai besoin d'être reconnus
j'ai besoin d'augmentation de salaire
j'ai besoin quand on se parle la
répartition de nos otages j'ai besoin
conçus par le nôtre sexualité et jean
pas ce réflexe que sa voix soit en jean
rose entre nous ont tellement la facile
dans les fait qu'en vrai qu'on se parle
je suis un clown alive oui ouais
il ya quelque chose qui te dit tantôt
sur lequel je veux quand je veux qu'on
vienne
s'était tu te dis en vieillissant on
s'améliore mais on change pas vraiment
puis se moque mais mes parents sont
séparés après 32 ans de mariage puis les
deux m'ont dit une variation de quelque
chose comme
au final on ne pas changer toutes les
affaires qui nous énervait au début
c'est les affaires qui ont fait que ça
n'a pas marché a besoin d'en rendre 2
encore une famille au complet piscine
seulement somme toute selon l'élu la
normalité de notre cité une relation à
succès le 10 mai quand même que 32
encore les affaires qui dérangeait au
début sur les affaires qui ont fait que
ça peut marcher
c'est toujours ça parce que tu es des
fois je rentre dans les relations des
fois puis je me dis à
tes le fameux quand ça va être réglé ou
quand ce conflit-là va être changée ou
qu'un femmes et s'y attend jorat la
fnade finir par arriver alors
mettons le nom mais mettons que je vais
garder ces exemples le t2 à face au non
mais là a maudit que ça ça les change et
puis moi je lui dis moi je veux que ça
change
d'expérience à jamais changée ça n'a
jamais fonctionné ce cette attente le
dos quand ça ça va être réglé
j'imagine que ça tu le vois aussi dans
des consultations du jacky qui pensent
que le problème est
qui pense que le problème est en surface
une petite affaire mais qu'au final
c'est ce qui ce qui est en dessous de
ceux qui
par exemple la ponctualité mais c'est
comme ça c'est un détail de la vie si
pour ya des gens pour qui c'est non
négociable si c'est non négociable
tu te rends compte que tu es quelqu'un
qui a du mal à le respecter c'est sûr
que ça va créer conflit mais quand je
t'entends tout je parlais des valeurs
des besoins quand dans l'ensemble de la
relation est ce que l'on veut c'est
vraiment important où on est en train de
mettre le poing sur quelque chose qui
nuit aux rays la relation fait que c'est
pour ça que c'est important définir
quels sont mes besoins à cette étape-ci
maintenant on prend la ponctualité tu
dis et cette relation est tellement
satisfaisant à ce point de vue le à son
enterrement de belle complicité mais je
suis dérangé par sa non ponctualité je
vois toujours l'être mais j'ai plus
d'accueil pour sommer ce pauvre est
convaincant nos problèmes tant est que
ça marchera toujours être dérangé mais
toi peut-être moins et donner de
l'emploi sauf peut-être mettre moins
l'accent là dessus parce que tu va
bénéficier de tous les risques mais si
c'est non négociable pour toi c'est par
exemple bon moi je suis pas quelqu'un
qui manque lynch je connais quelqu'un
qui furent mes haumea fume avoir un
titre fumée le titan pendant un an
bourse il est possible que oui les gens
peuvent arrêter de fumer mais il est
possible que non ces gens qui y est
allergique aux tenants allergique aux
chats à le trou au chaud elle ne
choisira pas toi ou de l'aude est chaud
c'est comme on s'en va déjà dans le mur
sexy comme tu peux battre à tenir le sur
toutes les légendes les médicaments qui
vont empêcher mais tu as tu vraiment
envie tu sors épuisé mais costaud oui le
jeu donne des exemples extrêmes et c'est
comme qu'est ce qui est important pour
moi bon impôt ponctuel mais alors on en
a les mêmes valeurs on a nos enfants
s'entendent bien notre sexe généracois
c'est correct mais c'est vraiment
l'importance de mes besoins mais valeur
à cette étape-ci sinon ça va être tout
le temps tout le temps quelque chose
qu'ils vont nous accrocher fait dans
l'exemple que tu donnes être en deux ans
de mariage si c'était des besoins
extrêmement important qui n'ont pas été
assouvie puis 32 ans plus tard y reçoit
font surface puis j'étais encore avec le
même besoin ça explique que la rupture
somme - puis est ce que tout ce travail
ou à m'amener des fois la conclu on sait
c'est mieux pour tout le monde que les
relations se termine ainsi encore s'ils
appuient d'amour au surplus d'énergie à
mettre dans la relation se la motivation
est - ce sont les gens vont faire le con
stockhom on s'adore on est beaucoup
attaché on a beaucoup d'affection l'un
pour l'autre mais on a pu suffisamment
d'amour pour aller plus loin puis sinon
il y en a d'autres c'est comme un énorme
aux autres on s'aime comme des fous mais
en même temps on manque d'outils
effectué ça dépend vraiment loup on est
ça dépend de ce que la relation a laissé
aussi ça c'est le propre de chaque
individu et y en a qui me disent ok
c'est notre dernière escale ça marche
pas ici avec la démarche on arrête puis
elle a d'autres qui se bat ce que ça
vaut mais choisit ni combo je laisse
tomber sur parce que le reste est plus
important faut juste que s'assurer que
la relation la porte encore satisfaction
que je reste pas là par résignation par
par incapacité puis bien qu'ils
choisissent que au lieu de toutes les
incertitudes faction tout ce qu'ils ont
construit tout ce qu'ils ont bâti
ensemble ils ont choisi de le rester
mais il ya des gens qui ont pu l'énergie
propre et tout le monde est malheureux
qu'ils aient eu des efforts pour régler
ça fonctionne pas ma nuit pour faire le
constat par contre vous faire le constat
que si on continue on va se muer en plus
compter à son propre détriment ce que ma
vouloir rester mais tout le monde est
malheureux là on y malheureux
personnellement le coupé malheureux les
enfants sont malheureux faut être
capable dit ben j'sais pas si je pense
qu'il faut trouver une façon saine aussi
de mettre fin à la relation et des gens
qui arrivent qui font un constat que
unis plus amoureux loin mais comment on
peut faire pour se quitter ses mains
parce qu'ils ont des enfants parce
qu'ils ont des entreprises pas scander
des propriétés parce qu'en plein
d'affaires axé puis sous un monument du
jeu les meilleurs amis du monde dans le
fond noir fait on aurait dû faire subban
est un métis qu'en savez bien que oui il
faut faire des choix puis photo ch
renouveler ce choix-là d'être en
relation avec la relation dans ce cas-là
maffre et puis dans la vérité de ce
qu'elle a montré pour s'attendre à une
idée on s'améliore on s'investit on
travaille les nappes naturel je pense
qui revient toujours au galop est-ce que
ce ça peut arriver maintenant du monde
que là la passion plus l'amour peu
importe comment qu'on veut la définir le
lait les ailes le sentiment que dans le
bas ventre en voyant quelqu'un qui
rentre dans pièce que ça c'est encore le
mais que que vous êtes qui sont rentrés
dans des patins de la vie qui ont fait
que là ils sont tranquillement éloignés
qu'ils ont encore le sentiment avant la
personne c'est une possibilité mais ton
de faire raquer tchèques ont fait table
rase on en a on recommence à zéro et on
recommence la relation au début avec
cette passion l'eau ou où sql et c'est
impossible de faire marche arrière une
fois que met-on j'ai pas deux ans après
le début d'une relation est ce que tu
dis là on a pris des mauvais pas atteint
on a pris des mauvaises directions
s'aiment encore qu'est ce qu'on fait que
je pense qu'à partir du moment où
celui-ci est encore là ben tout est
possible où tout oui parce que c'est moi
j'ai souvent quand j'ai un intérêt pour
quelque chose mais l'énergie du temple
des efforts quand j'ai pas d'intérêt je
n'ai pas d'énergie pas de temps pour
défend avec le jeune intérêt à mettre ma
relation au premier plan j'ai envie de
me inversée je voyais dans l'instant
journée d'énergie pour faire des efforts
c'est sûr qu'il faut y mettre
du temps puis des déconcentrations
pourquoi on sort du bateau mais dans la
mesure où j'ai deux individus qui
veulent qu pourquoi
essayer de récupérer la relation n'ont
rien à perdre mais j'ai vu beaucoup de
relations se renouveler après des
grosses crises après des séparations
après des séparations deux mois des
années plus tard revenir ensemble ça
prend deux individus investi ce n'était
pas ça comme je le répète on n'y ait pas
d'abus qui ait pas de violence qui ait
pas d'abus de pouvoir piquer pas de ces
deux choses qui ont brisé le groupe on
peut surmonter un paquet d'affaires dans
la mesure où il ya des gens qui sont
investis que c'est se reconnaître leurs
difficultés dans le leurs faiblesses qui
sont prêtes à se rétablir on absolument
puis j'imagine que que pas mal tout peut
surmonter le g11 les parents de mes amis
il s'entendait pas du tout sur la façon
de l'élever lui puis ont décidé piller
temps il y habiter ensemble ça faisait
longtemps et la zambie ont des titres
phares au québec on va faire garde
partagée on se sont chacun aller habiter
ailleurs par 1 pendant quinze ans puis
après ça une fois que lui était rendu à
ces vieux était en d2 en ont fait bon
ménage ensemble parce que oui oui
cela c'est tellement un point important
je pense que ça résume toute la
conversation qu'on a c'est que
maintenant c'est plus facile de se
donner le droit d'organiser une relation
qui répond à nos besoins et même ses
pots stable c'est pas conventionnel fait
que des gens qui vivent ensemble
il ya des gens qui vivent dans des
maisons séparées il y en a qui vivent
pas ensemble lyon et chalets comment il
y en a qui se voit juste avec les
enfants il y en a qui se voit pas il ya
tellement de former les hauteurs de
façon est en relation que d'êtres
humains ça prend juste le courage
s'asseoir pineau miss ou est-ce juste un
conflit qu'on nous on essaie dessus
comme ce fait les han han nommé lin 10
heures avec l'éducation du petit bain on
se fait vite sur ont fait chacun nos
affaires on s'aime on préserve la
relation la relation à l'enfant il ya
mille et une façons mais ses hôtes
d'assumer cette différence le ouais mais
en même temps surtout surtout dans le
maule excuse moi je choisis mais surtout
dans le moule de l'est de la cité dans
lequel on exulte et de faire sauf quand
même des entraîneurs de boxe le plus ou
même principe que tu moi je sais pour
pendant les prochaines relations ça va
être long avant que cohabitent avec
quelqu'un part fiscale a été la nature
de trop de problème le team et mais la
société dit quand même rapidement habite
avec la personne pitié question de pas
payés double loyer bluetooth et à faire
leurs preuves wade n'est qu'au petit
démarrage ensemble ces banques grecques
sauf que moi chez que ça va être la
prochaine fois faut pas que je fasse le
serment dessus dit clairement partant
puisque tu rech a créé des moments
d'intimité passent un week-end ensemble
on envoie des aspects de l'autre être
mais
à deux nations se méle il y en a qui
sont capables ne sont pas capables mais
déjà quelques qui cohabitent ça suscite
quelque chose avec des fins de semaine
c'est maintenant par exemple c'est
suffisamment mais tu le sais que pour
toi que si on traverse et un confort
lotus vêtements mais c'est ce que je dis
c'est que organisons la relation la
formule le mode qui ne convient puis à
l'inversé moi j'ai des clients qui me
disent eh oui moi je rêve d'une relation
conventionnelle mouche boesso un
amoureux une amoureux la fidélité
convient sans mac est un papa une maman
bébé une petite clôture pourquoi pas ben
oui tout est possible faut juste
s'assurer de nommer clairement ses
besoins là à l'abandon depuis que je
suis avec quelqu'un qui est un peu la
même vision de la même direction petit
et pas ce qu'est ce qui est les gens qui
nous écoutent qui pensent qu'ils ont
peut-être besoin d'être dans leurs cours
dans leur même son parcours dans leurs
relations futures c'est quoi les étapes
qu'est ce qu'on fait mais tant qu'on
veut aller chercher de l'accompagnement
on appelle à l'ordre professionnel des
psychologues ou des sexologues ou des
thérapeutes de coupe juste noce risque
d'aller chercher un support des fois ça
peut être quelques rencontres nous
donner une direction pour certains ça
peut être juste guern on va s'asseoir
pour prendre le temps de se parler ce
que la pandémie au fait beaucoup la
pandémie on laisse beaucoup en tant que
beaucoup de couples qui ont ce son qui
ont éclaté qui ont des idées de rond
mais moi j'ai aussi beaucoup de coupes
qui sont dits inquiets des situations
extrêmes comme cela arrive je réalise à
quel point mes petits problèmes puis
misery temps était bon mais banal parce
que l'important c'est qu'on soit
ensemble fait pour certains comme ça
peut être juste sur ce qu'on garde
pourquoi qu'on remet pour le coupe en
lumière à cause d'une bonne date par ce
même sommes obligés de consulter deux
fois l'exercice quand on se rend compte
mais beau qu'un jeune homme est beau le
cpo c'est pas des choix vestimentaires
c'est comme faire une attention
particulière de me rendre attrayant mon
coeur mon corps gilles gauche bonnement
j'arrive à la dette on est heureux puis
on fait le point sur notre relation
parce que dans le quotidien les enfants
le travail les noms rentrer dans l'hiver
on le sait quand tu déjà plus long plus
compliqué de remettre le coupe en
priorité des fois c'est suffisant juste
de onze partis d'ivresse à froid puis
des fois jose et on en est où dans la
relation si comme tu disais tantôt on
est satisfait mais oui j'aimerais ce
qu'on en fait un peu plus et d'accents
la tube sud un petit peu dérangé puis
tous les jours ce qui dérange elle seule
ça évite tellement de conflits à venir
parce que c'est tout de non-dits
accumulé 6 v au fur et à mesure mais oui
puis même si on est dû pour un gros
ménage de printemps ben vaut mieux
briser la glace que d'accumuler puis que
ça finisse par être le sentiment
amoureux ou de lits mais toujours la
partie qui sera karim abou cas cumulés
de sortir tout d'un coup que ce soit de
raison que je le proposerai pas comme ça
c'est comme tout ces insatisfactions là
qu'est ce que ça crée c'est la déception
si j'ai le sentiment d'être seuls
l'impression que on s'en va nulle part
j'aime pas sûr qu'on ait pu ans en fac
travaillons sur le besoin plus que de
sortir tout parce que là on est
complètement un rouleau de parchemin la
dette à sera pas le fond c'est quoi le
style de ce 10e et on se faire aider par
semaine mais il fallait des check point
tu sais quoi les dons nous appartiennent
à d'autres les conseils mettons qui
donne le plus souvent pour une vie de
couple en en santé il y en as tu
d'autres mets ton pain la communication
cas comme qu'elles sont obligées de
communicateur extrême souvent je dis
faites attention parce que la
communication le 32 % c'est le temps
qu'on utilise puis l'expression faciale
7% les mots le réel c'est du non verbal
et des fois les gens en parlent peu aux
nouveaux besoins du fatah à l'attitude
autant quinconces par des fois je vous
ai fait juste j'ai un exemple j'ai un
couple qui vient dans mon bureau elles
ont ils savent ils vont se laisser ils
sont arrivés au bout de leurs affaires
brive à savoir comme alpha budget juste
dit je sais même pas d'où ça m'est sorti
juste dit on sait tous d'être gentil
envers l'autre si le camp sont venus la
semaine d'après coûte l'attitude avait
complètement changé s'il vous plaît
merci le changer le temps c'est comme si
tu as ton amoureux tu parles
gerland face à ton fils que tu permets
tu en es stressé pour vos vies depuis on
est dans notre bulle cheikh faire
attention à comment on s'adresse l'un
envers l'autre donnée au moins une heure
et nagy trois heures le rituel amos et
trois heures par semaine où je m'arrête
puis le but c'est d'être ensemble au
delà des responsabilités des choses à
régler
divertir le coc divertir le couple sait
comment gens ne réalisent tout soit
réalisé pour on vit ensemble puis on
sera content pis par dessus tout je lui
dis rapidement tantôt on peut tu prends
l'attendait merci pour l'attitude gâteau
pour ce service l'optimum rendu d'être
encore là malgré tout mes difficultés
sont faits pour eux au début on fait un
on donne ce teint on est juste ensemble
quand on n'a pas de projet en ce que ton
sans embrasser sa fille et plus on est
juste à se complimenter pape se demande
comment ça qu'on est pas de même après
une formule c'est juste que le quotidien
de s'installer en zone ce temps on se
reconnaît par la police et on fait
attention à comment l express a déjà ça
devrait remettre le coupe circuit
même si la forme a changé vêtements un
passionné allait peut-être messi est
encore engagé ça va redonner un peu
d'appétit génération je me sens vraiment
de rester conscient jour le jour des
petites actions lundi parce qu'il est
tellement octet à l'inversé mettons un
ton un peu plus sec parce que tu es
stressé ou été dépisté à temps si tu es
juste mettons le matin était pour gpo le
typo est attentionné à l'autre mais au
matin une potée les petites affaires qui
peuvent être facilement ce qui paie si
on on nourrit possible puisqu'on fait
pas attention seulement l'attaqué mills
a fait un quotidien qui pas mal - bobby
phone que justement au jour le jour
essayer d'être conscient de ses petits
enfants oui si juste prendre la tête
quand on rentre à les saluer l'autre ça
fait tellement banal les gens qui
s'embrassent en avant de partir le
travail que tu étais tu présentes
étaient déjà en train de te demander
si on peut juste être présent taille car
quand ça prend 10 secondes leur donner
un baiser de bonne journée mais d'être
présents ça fait toute la différence de
regarder l'eau aux amish tintin nommé y
en a qui ont besoin d'être regardé si
c'était à refaire il faut se préciser
puis deux raisons ça peut s'accumuler de
faire un gros noeud relationnel
simplement faire la différence dans un
quotidien beaucoup plus sympathique
beaucoup plus aéré beaucoup plus léger
mais trop fine à une vie de couple du
quotidien qu'on classe épaules à la fois
que tu vends sur la jeune homme explique
le sénat
toujours belle
merci infiniment vraiment des merci
beaucoup d'énigmes et recevra cher mais
même chose c'est vraiment un bonheur
partagé c'était sympathique merci de
votre intérêt et votre enthousiasme
vraiment son contenu d'écoutés si on se
met la destination de trois belles
semaines et
merci à aa2 du contenu excellente offre
tout un tas de cartes combien
oui
si vous voulez plus de contenu excellent
comme ce que vous venez d'entendre aller
sur le patriote le pitch vous abonner
pour trop de leur part mme otis outre au
delà ouais trois pièces par horace par
mois et vous avez les podcasts en avance
acquise avec les premiers de votre
groupe d'amis à recruter les podcasts
qu'ils allaient avoir pouvoir avoir une
avance quand vous allez tire le la
dynamique entre les amis de tout le
temps avec une avance sur les jobs en
avance les entre deux toits mais avec
pétillante une avance sur l'humanité
complète en plus en plus parce que laure
chez le podcast su ni voulu nous
entendre jazz ou davantage on fait des
encore moins de filtres à préchac
podcasts etc là on vient de finir de
tourner le podcast on va en jaser on va
te filer nicole non on y colle il est
maintenant évident comme un fils
travaille la place travot de taza taille
est là mais on jase on parle de
conversion qu'on m'aide à voir mais ce
si vous voulez avoir accès
mais heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous c'est exclusif
sur pétule il faut s'abonner abonnez
vous